at the time you made Forbidden Zone
after all these years now they think
about the time that you put into it and
making it did you consider the original
release of failure economically yes I
mean it bankrupted me and I lost my
house but artistically I was glad I did
it at the time that it happened did you
feel that way or lately glad I did it
really okay Wow and so are you able to
talk a little bit about what happened in
terms of how it bankrupted you or I mean
just just maybe yeah yeah yeah I had no
idea what I was doing I didn't clear the
music rights the animation cost although
I had a very talented animator it cost
like 20 times what I thought it was
gonna cost and yeah you know I was just
starting in real estate and you know
part-time jobs as a busboy the cab
driver you know at forking money and you
know it was like some people go to film
school I just made a film have you
always done it that way sort of seat of
your pants and you just jump right in
and that's how you learn the good and
the bad
yeah yeah yeah did people try to stop
you it was just economic only economic
yeah I know that I I had to shoot it in
starts and stops as I get some money I
had a little bit of help from friends
and some partners mostly on my shoulders
right and then I'm assuming you you took
out like a second or something in order
to fund yeah okay and so then well more
than that and then to finally get it
released I'd to sign away all control so
I only got control of the film fully
back a few years ago Oh a long story but
I only got a hundred percent control the
Forbidden Zone a few years ago so that
what I'm sorry what was the time it's
been 15 years 40 years 40 years oh sorry
so the films done 40 years ago Wow 40
years okay sorry it seems like a 15 to
me yeah I know how are you thinking
about it every day
for the last 40 years no I don't think
about it at all think about the next
dinner the next article wine we're
pairing yeah yeah yeah my brother's
writing fantastic music that I have
going through my head you said music is
very yeah and I have a very been blessed
with a very rich family life
sure I've just I'm just hoping to get
little little nugget so we can you know
give to our audience because there's a
lot of people that we watch our stuff
that I'm not saying they haven't been as
blessed but that they want to know how
somebody gets to this level and and
that's kind of what will we do with
phone courage so well a positive
attitude is important although I don't
know how you convey somebody who has a
negative attitude to just tell it the
words have a positive attitude you know
if you're going to get knocked down
you've got to get back up everybody gets
knocked down everybody gets knocked down
you've just got to get back up and go
back at it so you weren't really
thinking about acquiring the rights back
for all this time
no someone acquired them made me a
partner it's a long story
and I only ended up with it recently how
would you say the theatrical release of
Forbidden Zone the first one where it
changed your life well we were in the
new Beverley theatre now owned by
Quentin Tarantino and there was the
arson threat and we have to leave no it
didn't change my life
well other than losing my house yeah
that changed my life but six months
later I had a better house you know with
some real estate partners you know
things worked out you know but again I
had to pick myself up you know and go at
it again yeah I got if I could give
anyone advice its tenacity its if you're
tenacious your odds are better the other
thing I've learned is you get periodic
Alpert
Unity's and we don't always take
advantage of them
we don't always I had a chip on my
shoulder with Hollywood for a long time
and I was courted by agents and
basically you know here's my card knock
on the door suck on note I don't need
stars you know I'll do it my way
whatever you know but it was like I
can't even tell you a few names that
reached out to me but now I have a
mellower view you know with with forces
in the industry and then when I have my
media company buzzing I got to see a
little bit how things work and how the
wheels turn so it kind of took the chip
off my shoulder you able to share how
you see things work
be aware that opportunities come up and
go for it even if you're gonna fail but
go for the opportunities when they come
up every one of them your biggest regret
I've read from people at the end of
their lives was not attempting to do
something I don't know how many times
while Disney went bankrupt yeah I know
it's a common thing we hear I mean cuz I
I know an actor gets to a point where
they say I don't want to work for free
anymore I want to be treated as a
professional and that makes sense so I
would imagine that's the same for
directing theater or our film well I
just directed some theater and when you
direct small theater even if you fill
the seats you're still gonna lose money
so that's uh
although the interesting thing on my
wife honest asia's in a theater company
force of nature productions and they put
up one of my plays last year and in the
play I wrote that there was this quirky
band so for the play we actually put a
band together for the play and now the
band is existing on its own and they're
in my new film Mambo de Monaco I think I
saw them playing and you were playing
the drums - yeah yeah
you know so I you know but I didn't make
any money from the theater production
you know we filled our 90 seats whatever
but you don't make money from small
theater you do it's the love of it well
you do art for the love of it and if you
make money then that's a blessing as
well but you're doing it for art and
that should be its own satisfaction
you